toulouse comme montpellier qui pourrait
basculer lundi en zone d' alerte
maximale face aux coronavirus en
attendant lille grenoble saint-etienne
et lyon seront dès demain dans ce cas
conséquences pour ces quatre villes
fermeture des bars et mesures sanitaires
renforcés pour les restaurants plusieurs
dizaines de propriétaires
d'établissements concernés par ces
mesures se sont rassemblés tout à
l'heure dans la ville rose en marge du
déplacement de jean castex réaction au
micro d' hervé grand show nous sommes
aujourd'hui les seuls à subir des
mesures totalement disproportionnée des
mesures qui ne sont contrôlées et
validées par rien il n'y a absolument
aucune prise en compte des dégâts
économiques et sociaux de la décision
fermer les bars et les restaurants dans
une ville c'est m 2000 3000 5000
personnes au chômage
quand vous recevez 1500 euros dead et
que vous avez 4000 euros de loyer c'est
insuffisant
nous avons pour l'instant deux simple
report de charges sociales elles ne sont
pas du tout annuler
l'urssaf nous renvoient tous les mois
des courriers de report ça veut dire que
pour l'instant on a toujours la corde
autour du cou et si la corde et
légèrement détendus ils peuvent nous
pendre du jour au lendemain si veulent
nous avons insisté sur le fait de
remonter les informations et sur le fait
aussi de l'urgence dans laquelle nous
sommes
parce qu'il faut agir de façon urgente
déjà et il ya pratiquement 30% de nos
entreprises qui vont déposer le bilan
d'ici
d'ici quelques semaines alors pour
limiter la casse il faut des mesures
urgentes dead de subventions et surtout
de paiements d'aidé des frais fixes et
non pas des promesses des promesses des
promesses qu'on voit rien arriver au
bout il ya l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mais à l'état d'urgence sociale et
l'urgence des affaires aussi